anything else needs to be mentioned yes
Fritzi if it looks like I'm not paying
full attention to you're a very handsome
man just stepped into this oval Wow
Josh Duhamel Josh come on yeah this is
John's ready for me oh yeah come on okay
yeah you know this show is on TV just
letting you know time you were here the
last time you were here you were
surprised that we were on - I know I was
in my sweats this time I woke up
literally 15 it looks like you just woke
up 15 minutes ago 30 last night really
the night before was my birthday it was
my birthday
two nights ago so yeah I had fun what
did you do one wait what's a guy like
you do on your birthday um what do we do
to dinner the pool party who was there
buddy mind Ryan and some other friends
friends good birthday 46 and by the way
I feel it because last night I was
playing superheroes with my son on the
floor yeah and I literally just a little
you know those little tweaks you get
yeah
next day I know my whole back seizes up
I could barely move laughs I could
barely get in or out of bed that had
nothing to do with the pool party though
did it might have yeah so Wheatley what
did I get you yeah hmm
what did I get him an appearance on the
show at early morn oh I got you a packer
loss last night as one I got yes you did
yeah I appreciate that I appreciate see
you probably loved watching the Packers
lose last night being a Vikings apology
I have to admit I don't I don't get too
upset about it
but do you root against them like were
you rooting against eBay or rooting for
Seattle the path I like to I like the
Packers organization I think that they
represent what I love about
about in the NFL Baron Rogers a love
errand and no way yeah
he's a good dude and and probably the
most talented passer I think I've ever
seen okay but do you agree with our poll
question has his career been a
disappointment well I think and I don't
know if if and I don't really care if
Packers organization hears me say I just
think that they're not surrounding him
with enough people I think they're way
under the cap aren't they don't they
have like 20 million or something yeah
that they could spend how often do you
get a quarterback that good and and just
sort of feel like they're just sort of
not doing enough to but haven't they
been doing this if you look that you've
had Rogers and Favre
yeah they should have two Super Bowls
yeah yeah so in the in the span of that
look at what the Patriots have done hmm
where is the Packers it feels like you
had Favre in you had Rodgers two of the
top ten quarterbacks of all time yeah
and you have two Super Bowl victories to
show for it yeah I don't think this I
don't think they spend like they should
honestly but okay who cares I don't I'm
good I'm glad they don't now you so much
I'm a Vikings fan I don't want the
Packers to be well how do you feel about
your - um I feel good I do I think that
we have a strong really strong defense
when we're playing well and when we're
healthy I think that Cousins is playing
as good as I could have imagined yeah
truth is I haven't seen a lot of
football this year I've been either gone
or traveling it's been a little bit
frustrating for me this year with the
football but you were I am going to the
Vikings Packers game though on the 25th
in Minnesota in Minnesota
oh so that you said Thanksgiving but
it's right after Thanksgiving in gets
two days after yeah three days after and
what movies you been you know I know
transformers is you know that that's
your big meal ticket right that's right
that was my annuity yeah I mean you know
that was great it's that all done I
think so
really I think so I mean we did five of
them and I think they just did a
bumblebee spinoff
so I don't know how much more that we
can do yeah but if Wahlberg wants it
done then you'll have another one right
maybe that pretty much he green like
yeah I just don't know if BAE will
direct anymore of him I think he's kind
of done with it but she did a movie in
austin with leslie bibb who's fantastic
played a cowboy you're accountable Oh
actually a goat boy I'm a goat farmer
well that sounds different than a cowboy
doesn't quite sound a sex how did you
prepare for being a goat for milked a
lot of goat did you yeah
spent a lot of time out at the at the at
the ranch
yeah you're from North Dakota you did
you ever you know come across this I've
never milked a goat before okay no
account was new for me I had milked the
cow is there a big difference well the
ghost they just hook him up to these
machines and they kind of do the milking
for you no I actually like it was on the
cow really yeah my son was out there
with me for part of it and he tried it
he thought the the goat was the cow was
peeing I can understand that
did you ever go to the Playboy Mansion I
have been there one time was it was for
believe it or not it was for charity
event it was for charity event save the
bikinis it could have been it could have
been any night that was that was
probably 15 years ago why not just me
well no because it doesn't exist anymore
what do you mean they sold it they did
yeah when did that happen that was like
a couple years ago really you know Hugh
Hefner died yeah yeah and then they sold
it
the party's over Josh okay I always felt
like I get invited there anyway I
thought it was kind of creepy though
when I went to the Playboy Mansion I
could the the decor yeah I mean I was
walk back in time but it was creepy too
the decor and then there are certain
rooms that you can go into and then
other rooms that are awful I wanted to
know what the kitchen looked like and
they're like nobody's going into the
kitchen I go okay
so I just want to peek in and see what
the yeah of all the rooms you you're
curious about the kitchens probably
wanted to last really yeah why the
kitchen I don't know I just thought well
let me see I'd wanted to take a tour
yeah but it was weird because I ended up
standing next to Ron Jeremy who Drew
Carey and salami from the white shadow
and and then we had a waitress one of
the Dom triplets and she was topless
giving us drinks and so ron jeremy and
drew carey and salami wanted to talk
sports I'm telling you the truth this
was my big you know and then all of a
sudden big fanfare Hugh Hefner comes out
in his robe and I felt bad for him
because he had to give the appearance
that he's still yeah he's still Hugh
Hefner and yeah these young starlets who
all looked the same
you know propping him up out on the
dance floor and I just said you know
this guy doesn't want to be out there
acting like I'm the coolest guy you're
already the coolest guy in the room so I
don't know you had to maintain that that
image I guess but at a certain point
thank you but you you work with James
Caan on Vegas and yeah he's gone I think
lived it for a while he did did you ever
talk stories with James Caan I of course
I did he's he's got some stories yeah
he's got more stories than anybody I've
ever met and you know when it would give
you a godfather stuff and yeah he really
is he's one of those guys that I he's a
purist in the sense that he says or does
things or says things before he really
thinks about it most of the time he
doesn't you know he just everything that
comes out of his mouth or everything he
does is authentic it's gotten him into a
lot of trouble but and he'll be the
first one to admit that but yeah he is
intimidating and I remember he was he
wasn't afraid to give me like notes and
scenes which he shouldn't have and which
I'm glad he did but I always knew one
was coming when he'd look at me and be
like hey Josh come over here for a
second
there we go and so he'd sit there and he
talked to me and and you know tell me
what like how I could do better and I
actually really loved it I needed it
wait but is that's not normal no I mean
we have to have a certainty ego to think
that I'm gonna tell you how to get
better and there's a certain you know
there's a seniority there that that of
course I'm gonna listen to what he says
I mean if it was some dude that was
younger than me doing that I would I
wouldn't have liked if Shia LaBeouf did
that to you did he ever do although I
might I might take I might take that
advice from Shia - he's pretty good
he's pretty good I've no pride I have no
shame give me a difficult actor you've
worked with a difficult actor that I've
worked with her story come on man you
don't have new names so who was just
difficult
[Laughter]
nice grin well it was it was uh I don't
know no I don't I don't really want to
get into that that's just gonna get me
into trouble
well just be vague with it I can't
really be vague without exposing who it
was okay you know what I mean
Paulie can you do some research there
Gary Busey never worked with Gary Busey
how are you guys doing what you look
great yeah yeah so back to this I miss
you guys it's your story here so we're
gonna yeah we're going to pick up these
news are you going again I'm gonna be
there now how do you get reinvade 'add
how do they invite you back because you
never know I mean it's it's one of those
things that you know and I've had
friends who didn't get that invite yep
and I know my times coming at some point
because but you you look forward to that
event just because part of it is such a
hard thing to get invited to but you
kind of sit there and you know around
the time that they come you're like so
you you get that invite and it's kind of
like Christmas in a way because there's
only so many that you get and there's
only so many people that they invite the
celebrities that are there yeah and it's
uh I could understand when you in you
could get your golfer who wants you to
play with him right and sometimes that's
your ticket in right the problem is they
put them in so many different every year
so I can't get a consistent player
starting to wonder if it's me yeah I
also saw where you made some headlines
when you did an interview Kristine Leahy
on Fox yeah and and and you were you
called out draymond Green
I did and then Golden State Warriors was
a big but you were doing you know
chivalry you were standing up for Fergie
and the anthem and you called out to
Raymond Green yeah and and did you that
they sort of Mott you with a video oh
yeah
they got me I took the L I took a hard L
on that one that's one of those times
you just gotta go oh my god what was I
thinking and even even when I said it I
was like mmm that might come back to
haunt me
and but I didn't when I said it I meant
it but why don't you lay down I'm on
Team Durant not team draymond listen I
got I got no problems with draymond I
really do I think he's an amazing
basketball player I think and I love the
Warriors I saw my feelings were a little
hurt
since when Curry was doing it I was a
Korean I Love You Man so explain what
the Warriors did after you you called
out dream on let's call them out in an
interview which is here we go I'm
talking about it again there it is and
and I shouldn't have done it
mostly because first doesn't want this
keep coming back up and I don't know why
I did it
Christine asked me about it and I and I
should have just passed like I should be
passing right now but so I said I said
it I meant it I didn't mean I should I
went too far scheana said a real man
would it does that was too much but they
heard it and they decided to make some
dance after the golden after the in
Madison Square Garden after they won and
then they sent that out and now they are
God how do i how do I take you know do I
just like put my tail between my legs
and just mash up of Fergie's yeah so on
so here it is right there on the big
screen and and so they're they're
playing the music here and she thought I
was hilarious too by the way
oh she did oh yeah she thought it was
really funny okay she's lazy good yeah
they're there all day oh my goodness so
they're all dancing there we should do
that I'm gonna be staff this is my
favorite right and look at the teamwork
with drayman and Kevin Durant like
they're actually in it together
icing their knees yeah yeah but did
Fergie say thank you for
standing up or did she say why would you
know she did as she said it was sweet
that she knew what I was that I was had
her back
but again I mean sometimes I just opened
my mouth I shouldn't it was just one of
those things that you dream on in what
fight no you could okay all right
six eight strong yeah but if you're
really mad well yeah you're defending
Fergie right I'm not gonna fight dream
on if that's what you asked okay just I
just said the S word
it's alright alright and just keep
moving alright yeah nobody would have
noticed until you I got anything going
on here coming up come back to bed
no I'm gonna come back to bed I feel
good I just got in ten hours of sleep
okay what do I got going on I'm taking
the rest here off I just finished that
movie in in in Jackson Texas Austin and
finally showing mine I know we've been
talking about this my last three times
out here we're done and I know I was
gonna have you do the the vo for it yeah
the voiceover I know you know what
here's the thing
god I just you know this is awkward
well here's the thing is so we had it we
had a book ended with me doing the thing
on the at the end of it and and we're
gonna have you do the front because
you're Dan Patrick you know would have
sounded that that smooth silky voice
yours would have been great yeah but it
really wouldn't have made sense for the
movie it would kind of come out of
nowhere
so I'm sorry man I am buddy games yeah
yeah yeah we're showing it to all the
distributors on the 29th and I cannot
wait but don't you think you'd you know
you get a little bit more fanfare
I mean Sandler puts me in his movies
just because I talk about his movies
over the air so I could have helped you
a little bit there but that's not gonna
I did think about that last night that
you were coming in and you kept saying
dude you got to do the voice-over dude
you got to do the voice-over and so I go
okay send me the script I'm gonna send
you the script you got to do the
voice-over and then I thought I didn't
like how did I get a role that I didn't
audition for but you were giving it to
me I would have loved if I would have
voted if I would have planned for that a
little bit better it would have been
great the Libyan bond is in this Olivia
Munn is in it
yeah Nick Swardson he's Josh Duhamel the
actor known for transformers life as we
know it safe haven the pride of Minot
North Dakota it's always good to see you
buddy you too my man thank you man
thanks for having us Josh Duhamel for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]